en el vídeo pasado teníamos dos alambres
paralelos con corrientes que iban en una
misma dirección y con eso vimos que los
alambres se atraían lo que quiero hacer
en este vídeo es ver qué sucede si las
corrientes van en dirección opuesta y
también quiero meter numeritos para que
podamos utilizar esta fórmula entonces
déjame pasar aquí abajo y voy a dibujar
otros dos alambres ahorita voy a hacer
mi dibujo un poco más en limpio entonces
aquí tenemos un alambre y pensamos que
tiene una corriente y uno que va hacia
arriba y que de este lado tenemos un
segundo alambre y que tiene una
corriente y dos y dos que va hacia abajo
vale entonces vamos a empezar a pensar
con esto con él con el campo magnético
de una no voy a dibujar la mano para
agarrarlo pero te la puedes imaginar
puedes imaginar que el pulgar va hacia
arriba entonces hacia donde irían los
dedos pues entrarían de este lado aquí
entrarían voy a poner la touch y si está
de que está entrando
y de este lado salen entonces de este
lado salen incluso por acá entra verdad
aquí también hay campo magnético del que
el que induce y uno pero es un poco más
débil porque está más alejado bueno
entonces y nada más como pequeño repaso
vamos a ver qué sucede con la fuerza que
ejerce el campo magnético uno en el
alambre número dos voy a escribir la
fórmula con un color neutral para no
cambiar tanto de colores y teníamos que
la fuerza que ejerce el alambre 1 en el
2 el campo magnético 1 en el 2 es igual
a y aquí tenemos que poner y 2 verdad la
corriente multiplicada por el producto
cruz de la longitud que nos interesa de
y 2 con el campo magnético 1 déjame
pintar por aquí la longitud que nos
interesa digamos que es esta de acá y
vamos a ponerle l 2 y que va hacia abajo
su flechita y que iba hacia abajo va
entonces ahora qué sucedería qué pasa
con la dirección de esta fuerza bueno
para encontrarla tenemos que utilizar la
regla de la mano derecha sin creo que
este está un poco difícil de dibujar
deja veo mi mano resulta que el índice
va hacia acá va hacia abajo es el primer
término el l2 luego el dedo medio
corresponde a b1 que aquí tenemos que
entra verdad en la pantalla entonces
tendría que ser más o menos como aquí
está apuntando hacia adentro de la
pantalla y aquí tendríamos los otros
dedos entonces la mano queda más o menos
así
vale y el pulgar apunta hacia la derecha
entonces la fuerza que ejerce el campo
magnético 1 en el alambre 2 va hacia
afuera hacia la derecha entonces ahorita
lo que está pasando es que el campo
magnético 1 empuja al alambre 2 hacia
afuera o sea se lo repele ahorita puedes
creerme o no puedes hacerlo por ti mismo
pero también resulta que el campo
magnético 2 y empuja a este alambre al
alambre número 1 lo puedes hacer con la
regla de la mano derecha o bueno de
cualquier forma que tú quieras pero esta
es la intuición que quiero dejarte hasta
el momento va que si las cargas o si las
corrientes van en la misma dirección
entonces los alambres que atraen pero si
van en dirección opuesta
entonces los alambres se repelen ok
entonces lo que vamos a hacer ahorita es
meterle numeritos a este ejemplo de acá
en el cual las corrientes van en
dirección opuesta para pues ya
finalmente calcular una fuerza así con
numeritos entonces pensemos que esta
corriente el ayuno es de 2 amperios
vamos a ponerle 2 amperes
hay dos es de 3 am pérez que están
separados pues vamos a ponerle que por
poquito para que la fuerza nos quede más
o menos grande pensemos que es un
milímetro pero ojo
queremos pasar todo al sistema
internacional para que albert para que
al final no nos hagamos bolas entonces
de una vez déjame lo pongo como 1 por 10
a la menos 3 metros 1 por 10 a la menos
13 es uno entre mil entonces esto es un
milímetro ok y bueno en vez de calcular
efe 12 vamos a calcular
efe 21 vale es de 21 aquí lo voy a poner
en entre pregunta para ver esto de que
también el campo 2 aleja al alambre 1
entonces vamos a poner una longitud en
este día acá pensemos que la longitud
que nos interesa la longitud 1 que nos
interesa es de 10 metros
pero más que ser una longitud es una
distancia verdad que va en dirección de
la corriente entonces le pongo su
flechita y entonces ahora es una
distancia de 10 metros hacia allá muy
bien ya tenemos todo lo necesario para
trabajar entonces vamos haciendo las
cosas con calma empecemos estudiando el
campo magnético que genera y 2 que
genera esta corriente que está pasando
en este alambre de acá primero vamos a
ver pues empecemos con su magnitud va
entonces empecemos y determinando la
magnitud de b2 el campo magnético que
induce la corriente número 2 bueno estar
acá es igual a como lo vimos en vídeos
pasados a mu multiplicada por dos
/ dividido entre dos por ti por r 22 por
pi por r entonces quién sería cada cosa
pues vamos a imaginar que estamos así en
el aire entonces vamos a ponerle muy
cero la permeabilidad del vacío les voy
a dejar el museo ahorita vemos cuánto es
en la cal q x y 2 la corriente
ustedes no le pongan peros lo va a dejar
así como 3 dividido entre 2 por pi por
el radio pero en donde nos interesa el
campo magnético pues justo donde está el
alambre número 1 es decir a un milímetro
de distancia
entonces el radio va a ser justo ese
milímetro que en metros es 1 por 10 a la
menos 3 metros y va a estar la tos y
ximo meter esto a la calculadora mejor
simplificamos un poquito antes entonces
este 1 por 10 a la menos 3 es un 1 entre
1000 multiplicándose con el 3 se hace un
3000 entre 12 son 1500 mil 500 por mu 0
/ / / p ok entonces ahora sí vámonos a
la calculadora a ver cuánto nos dice que
es aquí está
que la aprendemos la variable la tenía
guardada en verdad y tenemos y eso hay
que multiplicarlo por esa es la
permeabilidad del vacío y hay que
multiplicarlo por 1500 104.500 no
por 1500 y eso dividirlo entre pi entre
muy bien enter nos queda 5.999 985 le
voy a poner 6 entonces es 6 por 10 a la
menos 4
por 10 4 y como hemos estado haciendo
todo bien con puras unidades así del
sistema internacional esto de aquí son
teclas unidades de campo magnético
excelente ya tenemos la magnitud del
campo magnético número 2 ahora tenemos
que ver la dirección lo que nos interesa
es la dirección por acá verdad dónde
está el alambre 1 entonces para
encontrar la dirección y tenemos que ver
cómo son los círculos concéntricos
agarramos el alambre con el pulgar hacia
abajo hacemos así como un no me gusta no
me gusta y los dedos ahora van a ciudad
ahí tenemos el dedo y por acá sale y por
acá van entonces más o menos queda algo
como de este estilo
ahí está la mano y ahora los dedos hacen
ahora antes hacían esto la entraban por
aquí y salían por acá pero ahora lo que
está pasando es que entran de este lado
y entran de este lado y salen por acá
salen por tanque muy bien también me
entran de este lado entra de este lado
si se está ok entonces aquí tenemos que
está entrando ya tenemos la dirección
dejar de ponerle que esta es la
dirección deja de ponerle perdón que
esta es la magnitud y que la dirección
es que entra bueno este bueno pues ya ya
ya tenemos todo verdad para finalizar
nada más hay que poner la formulita df
21 la voy a poner con color rojo y que
nos quedaría nos quedaría que f 21 f 21
es igual a 1 y 1 por el producto cruz de
l 1 con el campo magnético b2 b2 cómo le
hacemos para encontrar esto de acá pues
tenemos otra vez que encontrar la
magnitud y la dirección empezamos con la
dirección que está pues un poco más
sencilla hacia donde va hacia dónde va
el e1 pues va hacia arriba dedo índice
hacia dónde va y b2 pues es el campo
magnético que va hacia adentro entonces
aquí tendría
poner el dedo medio hacia adentro y así
esta es una mano derecha esto serían
otros dedos y ya tendríamos la muñeca y
por acá tendríamos el pulgar
bueno se pulgar quedó muy gordo déjame
poner un poco más bonito entonces bueno
la existe es que el pulgar si no me sale
el pulgar está el pulgar va hacia la
izquierda y eso coincide con todo lo que
hemos platicado verdad que que se están
repitiendo un cable del otro está de acá
sf 2 1 y va hacia afuera muy bien
entonces ya tenemos la dirección déjame
poner una flecha de que es la dirección
y para terminar lo único que hay que
determinar es la magnitud
entonces la magnitud de f 2 1 y además
para terminar es igual a y 1 la carga y
1 que es de 2 samper voy a poner 2
amperes multiplicada por la magnitud de
l 1 acuérdate la magnitud de un producto
cruz es el producto de las magnitudes
por el seno del ángulo
entonces nos quedaría la magnitud de l 1
que es 10 metros 10 metros por la
magnitud de v2 que afortunadamente la
calculamos acá verdad por 6 por 10 a la
menos cuatro teclas por el seno del
ángulo seno
del ángulo entre el e1 y b2 pero cuánto
es este ángulo pues otra vez tenemos que
estos alambres están en el plano que es
la pantalla pero en los campos
magnéticos están atravesando la pantalla
perpendicularmente entonces el ángulo de
90 grados
y medios como prefieras y por lo tanto
esto es un 1 y acá nos quedaría 12
no 120 por 10 a la menos 4 y todo el
sistema internacional esto sería newtons
o bien podemos ponerlo como 1.2 por 10 a
la menos 2 a la menos 2 newtons muy bien
entonces ya tenemos que la magnitud de
la fuerza es igual a 1.2 por 10 al menos
2 newtons y la fuerza va hacia la
izquierda es decir los alambres se están
alejando ahora si conociéramos la masa
de este alambre y de éste al hambre
podríamos conocer la aceleración porque
conocemos la fuerza con la cual se están
alejando pero entonces qué pasa al
alejarse al alejarse estos dos alambres
pues el campo magnético de ambos cada
vez ejerce eso es más débil verdad
entonces pues y si es más débil eso lo
que hace es que la fuerza de alejamiento
sea cada vez menor y por lo tanto que la
aceleración sea menor pero cuidado
fíjate está aquí aquí hay algo padre
interesante aunque la aceleración sea
menor siguen acelerándose y por lo tanto
cada vez se alejan más y más rápido
bueno te dejo pensando en eso nos vemos
hasta la próxima